special announcement tonight long-time
rush limbaugh producer
beau snerdly his real name's james
golden is unveiling a new podcast that's
called rush limbaugh the man behind the
golden
microphone here's a preview
33 years of excellence in broadcasting
people don't remember what you say too
many words fly around it but they never
forget
how you make them feel this is rush
from the very beginning three hours of
broadcast excellent straight ahead
great to have you until now hosted by
james golden who you might know better
as bose nerdly
rush made no secret about it he said it
and it was just but it wasn't i
[Music]
was born to host and you
were born to listen here now to explain
more long time
rush limbaugh producer call screener bo
snurly
james golden and full disclosure we've
been
friends for decades sir great to have
you that's right
thank you sean thank you so much you
weren't able to talk about this publicly
at the time
yeah for the first few days i couldn't
talk at all about it
and i still get choked up and i still
find myself getting weepy at odd times
and just
random times and something will trigger
it
and you know it's just something you
have to learn to live with
you lost your mom the same week i mean
you got
hit with two shotgun you know double
barrel shotguns
um you talk about rush you've been with
them
almost the whole 33 years this
incredible journey this incredible ride
um you also talk about the person that
we know
is fair to say that maybe a little more
shy in real life
rush was very often after the show at
least quiet
and and you know and he was always
though he was not this
braggadocious all the time whatever
there was russian involved the guy that
was behind the golden eib mike
who presented an amazing show that
continued to grow
for 33 years think about that a show
that continues to grow for 33 years
and then off the mic he was a very
humble loving
gentle spirit and he was
generous beyond measure we are learning
stories now as we go through this
podcast series
it's 12 podcasts the first one was
launched today
you can get it on the iheart app
what we're learning we're hearing
stories i'll tell you one that we heard
just this week
we got about 30. one of the states where
there was a flood
rush found out about it donated to
a gentleman that was a liberal store
keeper so he could get his business
going
no publicity he didn't want publicity
that's the way he was
a truly great and humble man
i would give you more time and we'll
have you back for a much deeper look at
this but i don't want people to hear it
all on the podcast on the podcast the i
heart app
um james golden you're a dear friend we
lost
the greatest of all time rush limbaugh
thank you for being with us
we come back our video of the day
straight ahead hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else